Hier: der Direktorensessel von 1922/23.
Da: die Neuinterpretation von 2018.
Hier: der Tisch K10, Baujahr 1924.
Und da: die Neuauflage, Baujahr 2018.
„BauhausNowhaus“ – Möbelklassiker der
Bauhaus-Bewegung im neuen Look,
aufgelegt vom deutschen
Möbelbauer Christian Drescher.
Wir wollten eigentlich die Bauhaus-Originale
nicht auf ein Podest heben
und museal betrachten,
wie sie jetzt im Museum auch oftmals stehen,
sondern gerade das Gegenteil:
Wir wollten sie vom Museumspodest
wieder ins Leben holen.
Das ist unser Ansatz,
weil wir Möbel produzieren.
Und so kam die Idee,
offener damit umzugehen,
mit jungen Gestaltern zusammenzuarbeiten
und diese Bauhaus-Möbel
in ein neues Licht zu rücken.
Mit dem Bauhaus kennt
Christian Drescher sich aus:
Sein Unternehmen baut seit mehr als vier
Jahrzehnten Einrichtungsklassiker
aus den aus den 1920er-Jahren nach
– bisher streng nach den Originalentwürfen.
Im Mittelpunkt immer die
Gestaltungsregel der Bauhaus-Schule:
Form folgt der Funktion.
Jedes Möbelstück ist alltagstauglich
– aber nicht nur das.
Letzten Endes sind diese Möbel etwas mehr
als normale Möbelstücke,
nicht nur profane Sessel und Sofas,
sondern wirklich Möbel,
die einen Geist transportieren, auch
irgendwo so ein bisschen das ausstrahlen.
In den hauseigenen Werkstätten von Tecta
im kleinen Ort Lauenförde in Niedersachsen
arbeiten Handwerker
und Designer gemeinsam
– eine Arbeitsweise, die so auch schon
am Bauhaus von Gründer Walter Gropius
praktiziert wurde.
Walter Gropius’ Grundidee,
Kunst und Technik,
Kunst und Handwerk wieder zu vereinen,
war der Kern des Bauhaus-Geistes
und der Denkschule des Bauhauses
und ganz wichtig für die Resultate,
die aus dieser Schule stammen.
Junge Gestalter haben für
„BauhausNowhaus“
bekannte Klassiker neu interpretiert.
Die Berliner Designerin Katrin Greiling
hat sich den F51 vorgenommen,
den Direktorensessel von Walter Gropius.
Die Herausforderung war:
Okay, wie viel oder wie wenig
tu ich diesem Sessel an,
dass ich quasi Walter Gropius
noch gerecht werde,
aber gleichzeitig, dass man auch erkennt,
dass das eine Neuinterpretation von 2019 ist.
Mit neuen Oberflächen und Bezügen
hat die Designerin insgesamt
sechs verschiedene Versionen
des Sessels geschaffen.
Dass das Bauhaus heute noch zeitgemäß ist
– für sie der Beweis, dass die Designer
ihrer Zeit voraus waren.
Ja, das ist irgendwie faszinierend,
wenn man irgendwie sich so die Kollektionen
anguckt vom Bauhaus vor 100 Jahren.
Das waren ja alles Utopien,
das waren ja alles schräge Ideen,
die ja so an sich nie
in der Gesellschaft angekommen sind.
Das, was Marcel Breuer,
Walter Gropius etc. damals gemacht haben,
das sah man ja nie
in einem normalen Zuhause.
Im Jubiläumsjahr der Bauhaus-Gründung
inspirieren die Entwürfe
auch andere Kreative:
Die Berlinerin Jennifer Brachmann entwirft
von der Designschule inspirierte Mode,
der deutsch-kroatische Industriedesigner
Konstantin Grcic Einrichtungsobjekte.
Das Label „Neubau Eyewear“ aus Österreich
hat dem Architekten Walter Gropius
und dem Maler Wassily Kandinsky
zwei Sonnenbrillen gewidmet.
Möbelbauer Christian Drescher glaubt:
Die Designklassiker sind mehr als
wiederkehrende Modetrends.
Die Möbel sind natürlich
zeitlos und die Dinge,
die dort entstanden sind, und die Architektur.
Aber was uns noch immer reizt
und was wir noch als Ansporn sehen,
ist der Geist dieser Denkschule.
Ob Bauhaus oder Nowhaus,
für all diese Möbel gilt,
ob Baujahr 1919 oder 2019:
Sie verraten ihr wahres Alter
erst auf den zweiten Blick.